this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you guys for all having for having
me at your meeting today I'm really
excited to be here and so excited to
hear about all the great work that
you're doing with youth in your county I
was really great to get the
introductions that way so one thing that
we've really been trying to do in the
state for each team is to connect our
our 4-h resources across extension
because we realize there are a lot of
people an extension that are working
with youth but may not necessarily see
their connection to 4h or the value of
the connection to 4h that's happening at
the level and the local level two so I'm
really excited that you guys are all
part of the team and that we're doing
this great work together I should
probably start at the beginning by
introducing myself I my name is alexa
mae lee and i am the state stem
specialist here on campus in BB hall and
i am i call myself a science nerd all
the time i love doing this kind of stuff
and learning stuff but i came to campus
by working in the local level mostly in
Clinton County and we did a lot of work
with local foods there and connecting
gardening activities with nutrition and
healthy living and those are the kinds
of projects that you guys are talking
about I really enjoyed doing at the
local level two and I'm hoping we can
build this up across the state national
council has this sod new brand campaign
all about 4-h growth here and one of the
things National councils really good at
it translating our 4-h story into
something that's interesting for youth
and their families and isn't just
extension jargon which is good for me
because I talk an extension jargon a lot
so that's one of the reasons why on the
stem plan that I'm working on right now
it's framed and the idea of growth here
it's particularly fitting when we talk
about gardening
and also we talked about growing young
people this is all kinds of information
about why stem matters things you've
probably heard before there are so many
jobs out there that are related but
there's not enough people going for them
or they're all white men there's not
enough women there's not enough
minorities all that kind of stuff so we
can play with some numbers if you want
what I really want to show you is this
which is 4-h growth curiosity and the
reason that I love stem learning so much
is because i love question anybody else
like questions like learning something
new the challenge of discovery of
achieving based on something you've done
with a group or that light bulb moment
that a young person is figuring out
something for the first time we're
teaching it to someone else and we do
that in 4h all the time in the garden in
the classroom in the club setting in the
show ring wherever we are and so what
I'm trying to do is my stem plan is to
take the work that everybody is doing
across the counties and connect it with
a common thread so that we can have a
way to tell our story that's useful for
inviting new families and young people
to become involved to tell our story to
funders and stakeholders so that our
programs can be sustainable and grow
stronger and so we can learn from the
programs that we're doing so that we
could do them even better I've been
doing a lot of talking I've been in this
position for a year or so so I've been
doing a lot of learning about the
different programs that are happening
across the country and trying to figure
out what those common threads are and
this is what I've heard from people this
is I'm thinking about it as a learning
pathway so there are lots of different
projects lots of different approaches
a wave that this pathway might actually
look like for an individual but these
are common steps that we take so we
start out by sparking curiosity the idea
of inviting a young person into the
garden for the first time I mean I
remember one can he was maybe a fourth
grader or something and we brought him
to a master gardeners vegetable garden
and he asked us how we got the cucumbers
on the plants like that she thought that
we've gone ahead of time and glued them
all to the plants so they were all there
and he was just so curious how it worked
and sparking that kind of wonder and let
people letting young people see that
there's something new out there we do
that in a lot of different ways and then
we're hoping to build on that so that
we're providing opportunities for kids
to answer those questions so maybe next
time he would grow his own play and see
that actually it comes that way first
and then we take the cucumber off right
and then eventually these experiential
learning opportunities can lead to
investigations or engineering design if
the science aspect of their experience
is something that they want to do more
of so they might do some kind of
experiment about a pest that's bothering
their cucumber plant and try to figure
out a way to help it grow stronger to
get rid of the pasture or that kind of
thing or design a cage or tool or
whatever it was that would solve the
problem for their garden and then not
only that we really want to help young
people make a difference in the world
around them I mean especially with the
challenges with climate change and food
security and all these really huge
things that we're all facing we need as
many people as possible to put their
brain power in their creativity and
their curiosity to solve those kind of
and young people have really great ideas
for how to make that happen and I've
heard from some of your projects that
you've seen youth doing that too and
ultimately that's our goal in the 4-h
program is to have youth and adults
working together to make change for
their community so this is what I'm
really excited about trying to help
happen for 4h in in New York statement
so this is one pathway and then in the
bigger picture we have a portfolio of
different science and technology and
engineering activities and learning
opportunities for young people to be
able to experience so this is what I
think about as our program portfolio or
if you like though the logic model idea
these are our inputs and our outputs and
our outcomes and those kinds of idea the
big picture ecosystem of our stem
learning experiences so kids can do just
about anything and 4-h but it does help
us as professionals to be able to focus
a little bit so we have certain projects
and activities that are particularly
strong in New York State compared to
other states so our plant sides and
animal science and those kind of
projects are geospatial projects and
drones and most kinds of things and then
we're working on some emerging
technologies new project areas for you
so computer coding and sustainable
polymers and that kind of thing so some
of these project areas you may work in
and some of them you may not but the
underlying experience in each one of
these topic areas could still follow
that grow curiosity pathway with our
ultimate goal is that with young people
building on that Jerry ah citty to see
themselves as science people and maybe
want to explore science careers or do
service work in their communities
sighs to solve problems for ultimately
helping them to be good citizens and to
think about information in that way
where they're checking their evidence
and making good decisions and that kind
of idea so the picture that's in the
middle of this the circles are based out
of a positive youth development model by
richard learner so there are three
things that his research shows that
young people really need in order to
thrive and three things those three
things 4-h really provides so that's a
skill building opportunity a long term
caring adult and meaningful leadership
opportunities so that's why the this
particular picture in an ecosystem is
shaped in that way so I you leading a
community garden program or engaging
with the libraries provide that caring
relationship with a young person that is
really foundational to everything that
we need to do in youth development and
the volunteers that you work with and
the master gardeners and the mentors in
those spaces are really foundational for
making that happen and so it's our job
as a system to help each other do that
better and help our youth take a
leadership role in that way too so it's
also a peer mentoring experience and
it's building up the social capital of
our entire system and then part of that
comes from organizational culture change
and strengthening and growth as we all
practice these science activities more
and practices and learning about how to
ask questions that can be answered with
evidence and sharing our evidence and
learning from our programs together that
kind of idea also just mention all the
work that we do through extension that
engages youth is 4-h work so I would
would just be curious to see what you
guys think about this idea of growing
curiosity and
if it fits in with the work that you're
doing in community gardens and school
gardens and with master gardeners or if
there's anything that's really far off
base or changes you would make or
suggestion any thoughts you have about
it I like pictures to explain things I
particularly like this too because it
also can provide a framework for some of
our efforts with children and youth
audiences when we were doing program
with youth how do we fit into this
pathway where are we coming coming up so
I think that's a nice framework yeah so
I think it's really important to have
conversations and to build up
relationships between staff members I
mean when I worked in Clinton County we
had the advantage of being really small
so we had to run into each other at the
coffee pot in whatever and talk and
share and learn about each other's
programmed but in a bigger County that's
harder to do and I think that's
something we all have to be intentional
about so that any time I would want to
do a program that would involve
gardening or an agriculture kind of
angle it would be good to check in with
Ag staff to see what they're doing and
if there's anything that relates and so
vice versa if you and your horticulture
program are doing something that you'd
like to engage young people with it
before eh staff in your office need to
know about that it's practical for you
because they might have some resources
that are helpful already that you know
about but maybe you don't and then it's
also structural so all of our our youth
numbers and reporting and everything has
to go through the 4-h system so your
staff 4-h staff can help you figure that
out so it's really something that we
should be working on as a team and I
prefer a personal approach just you know
stopping by or calling up or emailing or
whatever the for each person in your
office to say hey this is what I'm doing
and how can we work together kind of
from my experience it seems like that's
happening pretty well in a majority of
counties but like any relationship it's
definitely something that takes
consistent work what you're presenting
to us here about curiosity grows here
that is something that 4-h educators
across the state would also be
introduced so too so there would be a
little bit of common language yes yes
and this is a relatively new framework I
started introducing it to forage staff
at State Fair last year and we're also
going to talk about it some more during
this spring in service the growth here
language is part of national council
stuff that people that 4-h staff see on
a regular basis and they have fun
graphics and that kind of thing so if
you're doing recruitment posters and you
need those sort that kind of support
that it exists so we're all sort of
learning through this together and then
you know come reporting time and we are
you know it's like who you know where
does that come in and I think I noticed
somewhere I down in the 5.8 section you
know that there were there were spots
for you know master gardeners doing
outreach towards you know that the
issues of childhood obesity and I and I
at the same time working with our 4-h
educator here trying to figure out you
know who gets who gets credit for this
where does it belong and our reporting
obviously you know it's done and we're
doing it together as an organization but
at some point it gets it can get
confusing so it is really good I think
to kind of work that out ahead of time
figuring out where it belongs it was
more of a comment than a question I
think and was did that I any sense it
totally does and I think that it's
definitely something that we keep
wrestling woods and try to find a better
answer for because we're all trying to
tell the best story we can about the
impact that we're doing and so much of
our work is integrated whether it's
across program areas or even topics
so within 4 H there are three focus
areas for our programming around stem
healthy living and civic engagement and
a lot of times the way the system setup
you have to choose one or the other when
in reality the program is both a end and
it's stronger that way so I think as far
as the plan of work reporting for
Celeste and that kind of thing it mostly
matters that there's it's not duplicated
so one person is reporting it and and
that it's in the system but one we
talked about it with the public then we
use the both and kind of idea so part of
the reason that we're looking at the
state team at our plan of work and our
strategy moving forward is that we can
if we have a more consistent core then
we can develop evaluation and reporting
tools to support the system at large so
that every person doesn't have to make
up an evaluation we could have a few
shared questions or tools or a toolbox
of choices for people to go to so we're
really excited this year for the first
time to have a 4-h spring and service
and we're stealing heavily from the for
the AG and service title we really liked
that so we're copying it and so the idea
is that will have a three-day conference
where educators from across the state
can come together to focus on youth
development needs and this grew out of a
club management conference that we've
had for a couple years which really
focused on community club delivery model
kind of stuff so there will be a strong
element in the program this year all
about volunteer management so that is a
huge part of our community club work but
we're also going to have a section
around building campus County
connections work around professional
development for youth development
professionals and another one around
communicating
impact of our 4-h work on Wednesday the
13th of April which is the first day of
the conference we're going to have a
special lunch / conversation opportunity
where we really want to bring together
people from local County programs with
campus faculty and extension partners to
have conversations and learn about your
programs and build connection so I'm
really hoping that that will tie in with
the work that you're doing in the
horticulture and service that you'll
stay another day and have lunch with us
learn a little bit more about our 4-h
program at the state level what we're
trying to do together and you're welcome
to come to the entire conference to yes
so the youth development and service
will be April 13 at ten a.m. until April
fifteenth at noon so it's a wednesday
through friday this in service is on
campus we thought we would have are
contemplating the idea of having tuesday
april 12 maybe from ten a.m. in the
morning till 5pm and have a horticulture
in service what I'm thinking about as we
were talking and looking at all the
faces who were not faces names who
showed up today that more and more often
we are working with youth and we are you
know we're integrating nutrition
vegetable gardening concepts into our
programs and I don't know speaking from
my own perspective we did not use to do
a lot of work with youth and families
but I think that all of us could
probably benefit from you know hanging
out perhaps an extra day and seeing
what's going on so I mean that was one
of the one of the ideas was to you know
have them close together adjacent so
that we could get some crossover and
both
directions and see what room there is
for collaborative efforts we too would
invite them to come the day before
anybody who is maybe in the youth
development area or nutrition area who's
like I need to know a little bit more
about what happens in the gardening or
horticultural area they could an
individual could attend are in service
we haven't even planned what we would
have at that any service but we think
that's a good that's a good day to start
thinking about what we could have there
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu